[Music]
what is oh
you you
[Applause]
you hear that God damn that's the sound
of patriotism boys
oh yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm riled up I'm
riled up quick let's go to the Capitol
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
ain't that the Jew part welcome
everybody to leftovers we are in our
underground 20 billion dollar fortified
secured uh highly classified location
join of course by Hassan picker
who is a primal I am Primal that's right
ever since ever since last week when I
met my idol and and uh the legend
himself liver King I've just been on a
steady diet of just straight raw liver I
haven't eaten anything else okay can you
imagine actually doing that yeah he he
impacted me I haven't used deodorant
body wash yeah soap we know yeah man
thank you that's a tenant in the words
of liver King thank you you know we
still got some uh bull uh I saw a fridge
you know we got not gonna lie it was a
little triggering I I opened I opened
the refrigerator door to get one of my
coffees and uh I got hit in the face
with bull [ __ ] actually can one of you
guys take a photo and post it on Twitter
so people can see but I I think we got
to get rid of that because it's just
really not a pleasant experience yeah
get rid of that by [ __ ] throating it
he also said Chef uh Chef uh player D
there whatever
yeah he said it only lasts a week that
shit's pickled and [ __ ] he says it goes
bad after I don't know how you I don't
know how like a pickled thing could go
bad no it's actually of the fridge that
is very that is very suspicious that
like like pickle dick goes bad like it's
[ __ ] pickled what do you mean is a
fermentation process it's like they used
it in the olden times to like you know
make things last not on [ __ ]
um this episode and salted pickled [ __ ]
is brought to you by
don't say it like that no
because we love them
I hate the episode is sponsored by
stamps.com thank you yeah so but the um
the liver King episode was fun it went
well I think it went great yeah it was
super fun it went great people were very
upset uh as always why what did we do
there's a lot of like medical
misinformation that was spread at an
alarming rate obviously I mean but what
happens when you expect it is expected
you know but the the next episode we did
a lot of um take backs not take
basketball clarifications you know yeah
like for example like you know cell
phones don't cause I mean you were on
that [ __ ] you were on that I I just
didn't know enough about the mess I
tried but then immediately I I like
looked into it right after and they're
like life expectancy is like 30. yeah
they have the lowest life expectancy of
all those like uh tribes yeah and I was
and you know obviously a big part of
that is because like they don't have
access to the health care and another
reason is obviously because like life
expectancy diminishes when you have
child mortality right right and the
infant mortality compared to the other
tribes out there yeah they're the worst
tough but
the the other thing that I will have to
stress I watched uh one of my one of my
fans is like he's like a documentary and
he actually went down there
oh yeah yeah I I apparently have a lot
of people in my community that have like
met this tribe uh which was very popular
for an isolated uh no they do uh I think
they do like tourism they do like uh
they there's like a thing in Canada they
got some cash they get something other
than liver guys they invested some
strawberries and stuff so
um that'll blow their mind in that video
they were talking about how they like
you know have this sense of community
and they like will spread the the sheep
that they just sacrificed to the entire
Village and how they do that
and the guy goes yeah this one's for the
village Elders okay the rib the best
part of the [ __ ] meat is given to the
Village elders
and the guy goes oh okay so how old are
The Village Elders he goes 28 plus oh
[ __ ] and I was like wow that's that's
exactly my life that's like being on
time
right that's true Obama's right dude I
ain't never met a 28 year old who was
who was a wise man you know what I mean
there's no no that's what I'm saying
it's like it's like the same as the
Messiah tribe and Twitch streaming uh 28
you're an elder
that's insane sorry I just always open
the stream and then get a little slam
there of audio so um it was fun though I
had I went I was going back and watching
it and I was super entertained I mean
obviously the guy's full of [ __ ] with
peace and love we love liver King he's I
love liver King how dare you that's so
Primal for you to say yeah it is and I
fully I acknowledge that also seem like
you've been taking your liver
supplements Ethan yo so I don't know if
you heard this but I was planning on
taking all the bone marrow and liver
supplements but then I realized you have
to take eight of those they're massive
pills a day so to do all three of them
I'd have to be bulking 24 massive
[ __ ] pills a day what the [ __ ] okay
that's like raw liver at that point it's
it's and I was like I'm not doing that
liver
yeah that's crazy that's also real milk
and hope that's how he got as rich as he
is I think I think oh yeah we realized
the answer after the fact okay update I
have an update directly from liver King
himself he DM me afterwards he did yeah
he did DM me before we're talking about
Steve's uh he he noticed that I am uh
Primal so yeah you're right that's and
that's okay I'm gonna read it
I'll retract my position on video games
it depends on the game and if it was
earned to be certain a promo game that
is first earned can be problem as [ __ ]
liver King out oh face yeah
out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah okay good so so but yeah I mean his
story of video gaming was pretty wild
that guy takes everything way too far
that [ __ ] went home while his
wife was in the hospital to play Halo I
saw that's some real games a lot of
myself in him I'm not even kidding like
that especially with that story I was
like do that no but I am such an addict
overall that if there was something that
I was like hyper addicted to at that
time I could you would leave here yeah
even in a moment like if I had a wife
and she was pregnant like I could
totally see myself [ __ ] up big time
okay shout out uh all the future women
in your life no well that that's why I
control all my all my habits you know
what I mean I maintain uh like pretty
strong grip over my addictions what's
what have you been most addicted to in
your life
I've talked to us before cigarettes
alcohol
um
and then other than that food like
unhealthy Carby really bad things that I
I used to eat I had a really shitty diet
back in the day you've conquered all of
your addictions yeah the food was hard
though it comes back it's creeping in
you know you have a slice of pizza and
then before you know it you're [ __ ] a
box deep that's the thing about being
addicted to food is that you have to eat
food every day with all the other vices
you can just quit it forget it trigger
warning for people with eating disorders
obviously we're not saying that like I
am a walking trigger a trigger for
people with eating disorders no they're
not watching this show well I'm just
saying because like people just can't
people get very touchy over that subject
and
um I just uh I'm not saying like food is
bad for you food is obviously good which
is what you were stressing about how
nobody nobody thought you said that
food is bad have you seen Twitter have
you opened the application Twitter or
sometimes even your own stuff right
sometimes I feel like we yeah
instead we go too far to over correct to
uh clarify obviously I agree but you
know it's good that people understand it
get it out of the way you know so uh
before we actually the document today
the juice is all here there's a lot of
shenanigans going on in the political
world lots of great videos to watch Elon
Musk is being forced to buy Twitter
which is funny but probably
I mean it's not going to change Twitter
let's be [ __ ] honest except like
Donald Trump coming back and [ __ ]
posting which is probably which is good
I love it yeah that's a problem I'm a
big fan yeah that will be like one of
the worst things that in Tesla plaid are
the two good things that Elon has done
Tesla plan well uh will got a Tesla
plaid mm-hmm
and they have like a launch mode yeah
and like we're taking boys you and I we
both have the same car for those of you
who don't know and like take hand
doesn't take hand kicks in like super
hard zero to sixty because it's electric
electric vehicles have like no problems
uh that uh the the you know internal
combustion uh engines have with respect
to like torque and whatnot so they go
really fast
really quickly
the plaid
is an entirely different experience
it's it hurts yeah I've heard it's super
what is it in like two point or it's
like one point something it's the
fastest 0-60 speed I think other than
like a conics felt or whatever some like
two million dollar car yeah yeah uh and
0 to 60 1.98 seconds yeah that's insane
do it when you do it
your your organs stay behind it doesn't
feel safe when I don't go that fast like
it feels irresponsible
thank you love
is another thing you put it in a coffee
machine it's a little pod and you secure
it oh okay got it Koenigsegg is actually
like a very famous uh Ultra Luxury oh
[ __ ] vegan electric vehicle car
manufacturer that has been around for a
very long time even before like EVS were
mainstream and popular hold on bro this
is [ __ ] so annoying this is trending
already
oh stop food is bad [ __ ] bro 42 000
number one yummies trending [ __ ] damn
yeah it's so annoying damn that was
quick
um so we got a lot of good stuff here
before actually I just want to flaunt my
hot new Teddy fresh shirt that just came
out today
you want me to read this yes it's super
inspiring
it says
you should always be your biggest
advocate
it's been a difficult year and you
should
be proud of yourself for rushing so
through got a lot of good stuff
make sure to set time aside for yourself
so you can focus on your mental health
and
self-improvement
it's upside down it's hard
if you don't have your health you don't
have anything [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] so right
pettyfresh.com
why is picking up why is the Grim Reaper
saying that I'm holding a [ __ ] nine
at me with a kill shot because it's
badass bro
it's a culture thing bro yeah I like it
thanks man
thanks so much all right that's it
I mean you know there's lots of other
stuff but I talk about it all the time
all right let's get into the fun stuff
shall we haven't talked about politics
here in like two weeks I know we were
gone and then we're done we're done with
that stuff yeah we've moved behind we've
moved behind we've moved on to health
and uh Fitness yeah we moved on a liver
but it's political [ __ ] but speaking
of uh
MTG everyone's favorite Titan
uh margarine Taylor green she's released
an ad of her haunted hunting hogs
in a helicopter
um
she also apparently points the gun at
someone's head Ted Nugent did this first
okay this is this is she's biting she's
biting Ted Nugent sweaty and it's not a
good look okay Ted Nugent and Pigman
very famously shot machine guns at Hogs
uh from a helicopter a very long time
ago I only know this because I was a big
Joe Rogan boy back in the day and they
used to talk about that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time he loved it and I'm not
gonna lie it did look kind of cool okay
well there's nothing more Macho than
ripping a railgun at a hog I think 200
feet I think like well there is a there
is a a demonstrable negative impact that
like Hogs have they're super invasive in
an environment so like you have to hunt
them with a [ __ ] minigun but I think
that's a little yeah that's over the top
but but by the way what's I mean you're
also flying over like a diesel engine
that's burning fuel at like a million
cars per second oh for sure I'm not
saying that they're in environmentalist
I'm saying well there's a difference
between like trying to maintain a
balance in an ecosystem
uh like hunting for for that purpose so
you heard it from a son the Hogs had it
coming oh for sure here we go oh you
know I'm you know it baby I hunt hogs
boy
it is
we've got skyrocketing inflation High
diesel fuel Democrats America last
policy
is that why she said we got high diesel
fuel that's why I'm in a helicopter and
it's like what do you mean you have a
five thousand dollar [ __ ] kitted out
AR okay I mean it's not as tactical as I
thought it was going to be but it's
relatively tactical okay you're getting
into a [ __ ] helicopter
to to shoot bullets that are way more
expensive now shouts out the Joe Brandon
for that okay and a bunch of [ __ ]
Hogs
don't act like you're with it don't act
like you're with the people also why
aren't you at home with your husband
Marjorie oh wait
[ __ ] yeah
she [ __ ] the Pilates instructor yeah
she's getting divorced her husband just
filed for divorce I can't imagine why
she's such a pleasant you know she's
just such a breath of fresh air to be
around all the time I'm sure that had
nothing to do with the divorce yeah
Democrats aren't the only one destroying
Farmers ability I'm going to do that
right now
oh that's not what you mean we've got
wild hogs destroying Farmers field so we
decided to go hawk so is this a problem
in the in the middle wherever she where
does she represent what state is she
from
uh she's a real estate developer oh so
the Hogs don't you don't think the Hogs
uh affect her daily life no oh and she's
from Georgia right
yeah so is the Hogs is a big problem
that's affecting our our people our good
people of America well hogs in like the
South and deer in the Northeast are
still like they if their population is
not controlled they will become like
they will become a problem to the
ecosystem I said God bless man if any
animal can flourish on this Earth just
let them go man you know what I mean let
the Hogs run wild Marjorie the way I see
it you're a hog people might get that I
mean the way I see it is like our our
existence and I was like impossible to
impossible to maintain like a Natural
Balance with which is why you sometimes
have to engage in this kind of like
pushing and pulling and it's people way
smarter than me that understand like
what the limitations should look like
that set that that's why you get like
hunting permits and whatnot also it
should be said
um that feral Hogs are not uh they're
not native to North America they're like
invasive species let them roam
I mean there are lots of other things
that we don't shoot am I an invasive
species I suppose you would be yeah this
is why Dan's not a [ __ ] vegan this is
why he's a vegetarian look at him he's
like all on board with pig hunting I'm
not actually I think it's gross but but
yeah right Dan but I'm just I'm backing
up what you're saying about them [ __ ]
up the environment they're not [ __ ]
pig I would not I would not be able to
do that I love Piggies you should be
ashamed I love Piggies all right well
here let's get to the good part
yeah
let's go eat eat [ __ ] it
reminds me of shooting down villages and
Nam give me good memories that is
analogous yeah well 100 they do that
because they're fantasizing about like
shooting Vietnamese Villages that's 100
what this is back when back in the good
days we used to shoot Vietnamese
children instead of hogs
by the way she did not definitely did
not shoot a hog that was like
it looks like
yeah you give me a fight there or
something yeah it
is
no I'm having flashbacks
oh clad into Klein water yes do you know
about his cleanse Klein water thing I've
heard that he's terrified of uh I'm not
gonna say the name of the band
oh and you'll sing it created clear
water revival created Maybe
one of my favorite songs questions
they're great bands greetings it bothers
all of us believe me yeah first what is
it Credence Clearwater band lead-ins
Clear Water please
clear water I'm gonna walk dude I'm
Revival yes dude yeah he has a phobia of
some sorts about that band he thinks
that whenever that band's songs are
playing or anytime someone utters the
name something terrible is gonna happen
no I'm scared yeah dude you're [ __ ] CL
but they're called look at a twitchcon
watch your bags clean and they're called
Clayton's Klein water I think sure yeah
anyway back to the hog yeah I don't
think she actually shot it Howard
[Music]
show the kill shot coward
[Music]
oh no show it here's the huggy
you hate to see a pig kill another Pig
like this
cannibalism is never cool man it's just
[ __ ] up it's hog on hog violence and
I'm sick and tired of allowing this to
continue no one is addressing this
that's so true it's despicable
Let's Help American farmers out sign up
below and let's go in that helicopter
and go hog hunting enter to win now why
she all raidened out God these people
are so [ __ ] up they're so stupid and
dumb and I love that they didn't even do
a good job that was horrible sucks
stages they just like
put two like little
let me ask you like genuinely speaking
like what is this supposed to mean
because you just gotten a helicopter in
ogged so what does it mean now that
she's possessed with the god of
lightning like American politics is a
sequence of aesthetic uh markers that
you have to associate with that's why
people like Ted Cruz for example often
will make themselves seem like their
working class even though you know
they're not rated they want the [ __ ]
like Yale and Harvard and [ __ ] but they
put on a they put on a fake southern
accent and put on like snakeskin boots
and a belt buckle and go yeah this is
what America's about same Kelly Lefler
did this uh before she got owned in
Georgia if you remember Kelly Lefler is
like the husband of the CEO of the New
York Stock Exchange I think or some [ __ ]
like that and she was she very clearly
despises the peasant class right but she
put on like a denim shirt a denim vest a
denim hat and was like I'm one of you
look I love hunting and it didn't work
because people were just like nah you're
not racist enough shut up Kelly like you
ain't with it you wasn't with me you
weren't with me shooting in the gym but
um
basically that is what is going on here
that is what's going on in every
campaign the problem with the Democrats
usually is that they don't even know
what aesthetic marker is actually
adequate and appropriate they don't know
how to lean into like the right memes
whereas the Republicans are very good at
leaning into this sort of thing like
like we're pig hunting like it's just
it's normal this is what Americans do
you know what I mean
yeah I wonder if there'd be a winning
campaign somewhere for a lib to be like
I got my license I went through all the
proper channels and we're gonna be out
here doing an ethical killing of a hog
yeah it's uh that sounds incredibly lame
when you say it like yeah not that good
it doesn't really play by the way I love
how it says stop communism all of a
sudden like what what when did you even
mention communism the Hogs dogs are
communists I am Hogs ain't you red
Animal Farm you fake Call Me ass grifter
dog [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I believe
that was xqc talking about you yeah I
know I know didn't you guys recently
like hang out and do it we he was on my
other podcast fear and
um because of uh Mr Mogul Ludwig himself
uh who wanted to uh mend the gap or
repair the bridge okay he apologized for
literally that statement among a million
others that he threw my way and openly
admitted on the podcast he was like yeah
I don't believe any of that I was just
saying it because I was pissed off and I
wanted other people to be angry at you
okay okay so do you guys you guys squash
the beef we're on do decent terms now
yeah that's nice yeah that's nice the
lugwood was able to to broker that I
need
I need to send logo without a Ludwig out
there from my bath you got a lot of work
to do for me man yeah but unfortunately
the sound bite uh does does still exist
no that's funny now yeah your balls off
my face man I love that was my favorite
one no he was like it ain't going
through a spiral
um which like I said he admits and if
you guys want to find out you can watch
it at fear and
fear and ladies and gentlemen yeah
um
here this is this is a Good callback
we obviously had great enjoyment out of
Steve will do us job 13 story will
jurget Steve will yank it Steve will
Jerk it will crank it for example when I
jerk off Donnie yeah and so now as we
predicted they would do
uh here's Martin Bradley talking about
how did
Bradley Martin
uh close enough I mean you just reverse
it usually you say it completely wrong
so yeah Zoo culture yeah I'm all yaked
out man I can't keep track of
yeah so as we predicted we should here's
how we mend that divide okay
we go to zoo we go to his gym okay we
get whatever kind of gorilla steroids he
has okay we shoot up you and I both and
then we get [ __ ] jacked that's it we
don't even need to be friends with him
we just get jacked though he would
definitely respect me more if I was yeah
for sure oh absolutely I feel it I feel
like a guy like that
even if I killed his grandma but I had
like a good like thighs and biceps or
whatever you're like kind of calling me
out he's like I'm just letting you know
you're kind of calling me out as well
but you're I'm right yeah you'd be like
dude I respect those quads I'm pissed at
you for killing my grandma but I respect
those [ __ ] because like if you've
ever worked out and and like have been
able to reshape your body in the way
that you envision it to be
you understand how difficult of a
process it is our juice is hard there's
a lot of ups and downs so even if
someone's like doing steroids or
whatever like I always I will always
have like a little bit of respect for
someone who's been able to do that
someone who's been able to you know
achieve an impressive feat like that I
agree it it's not something I personally
care about but I definitely acknowledge
the amount of work it takes to do that
yeah and it's all you too it doesn't
matter how rich you are how poor you are
how I mean it certainly helps if you're
rich
regardless you still have to do the work
yeah nobody else can do it for you yeah
and I respect that but maybe to bury the
hatchet you think Bradley will come on
here and share a bite of bull [ __ ] with
us
maybe not with us because we're beta no
I want to bury it with Bradley he seems
like a nice guy you want to bury your
bull penis in his mouth is that what you
want to do no I don't want to put my I
don't want to do that well yes I do want
to do it you just said you want to put
your bull [ __ ] in his mouth Bradley I'm
inviting you
to accept my
Fat Bull [ __ ] it's very long into your
mouth it's salty if you chew it too very
salty it's very chewy and very juicy
but uh in the end oh you fell off uh
I can't believe you you're Primal
casting
yeah so
anyway uh as we predicted Bradley and
Steve will do it or tried to be like nah
we were just kidding I can't believe
they were they believed that story here
watch it's like
yeah it's like how people are always
going to comment something negative too
right yeah there's people that like for
example at the beginning no one ever
said like I love Trump I love Trump I
love Trump or what whatever case it was
but people will think it but they're not
going to comment that it's going to be
all the people that are like [ __ ] this
guy [ __ ] this yeah [ __ ] this guy you
know yeah what you know that's just the
self-published yeah he just loves Trump
no one no other not everyone is like I
love Trump but I'm gonna keep it a
secret because I'm afraid that like you
know my non-trump supporting fans are
gonna hate me yeah I think you just live
in L.A bro it's a Vibe right now and
everyone and you're you know
even before the pot me and Steve were
like oh to be funny we'll like think of
like three like funny stories that are
complete jokes and just kind of like
straight face them
and then talk about three like current
topics right so that's exactly what we
did but Bradley I know your ass can't
count to three stop trying to [ __ ]
pretend like yeah
those reps he knows how to count to
eight at least that's right exactly
that's a good point you do reps yeah I'm
just spitting facts you know try try and
contain the hater I I will never
understand why dues with big thighs wear
like super [ __ ] slim fitting pants
it's just a it's a pet peeve of mine two
things I can't stand are like the
sleeveless hoodies and dudes who wear uh
dudes who have like massive [ __ ]
quads that wear super skinny it's
unrelated to the subject matter I'm
sorry well no but you remember his fat
thighs in the original video he had him
riding all the way yeah no I love that
like give me more of that come on oh boy
come on over here this is our what our
fridge looks like every time you open it
for a Coke Zero or something I can't
even look at it bro that [ __ ] is is
traumatizing yeah it's disgusting why'd
they I'm so pissed that they left it
here yeah this is a gift I'll [ __ ]
give it's a liver gift
yeah you guys um
Bradley the invitation stands come share
some [ __ ] with us
fat juicy salty pickled [ __ ] we can
bring Steve we'll do it too but it's not
dog penis which is apparently his
preference preferred penis animal penis
of choice
he doesn't want to eat it he wants to
jerk it jerk off Donnie all right here
it is
and then I see is that pod still up that
pot's still up the one it almost has
like a 800 000 but anyway so sick um
there's one story that like kind of got
taken by all these like yeah you know
why it has a lot of views right
yeah because it wasn't because it was
like a dull podcast
I disagree I thought it was a dope
podcast bro did you watch the whole
thing [ __ ] no exactly what yeah I did
actually other channels yeah talking
about the dog so like Twitter yeah like
Hassan Hanabi or whatever the [ __ ] that
guy's name is
actually actually though respectful King
watch what he says after I don't mean to
distract him at all and then oh dude
[ __ ] okay that was actually super nice
we're good we're good yeah no we're good
yeah we're San and I whatever the [ __ ]
that asshole's [ __ ] name is you know
Hassan go back to your sand country
piece of [ __ ] I mean no disrespect no no
no no he was a respectful King he was a
respectful game no no I'm kidding I
don't think he meant it like that I I I
it's fine no I gotta I gotta I gotta
defend my boy here
you can't take this from me I'm
defending him
I'm the number one Bradley Martin
Defender all right all right
and then H3 oh well H3 talks about
everything we did so this is my question
oh and then also I was kind of surprised
I was kind of impressed because Kyle
also was fairly respectful here he just
said oh H3 talks about everything kind
of impressive I think he meant it in a
like
I think he he holds me like a like a
drama farmer he said everything we do
right and that's I mean I do talk about
them uh somewhat frequently you know but
but I feel like he could have been a lot
more of a dick
which which wouldn't be a problem for me
obviously I mean he knows that I love it
so but he was he was respectful I think
as far as what he could have said also
in the grand scheme milk
they're like a medium Target for us like
well three things we talk about
everything they do but like he's no
Jordan Peterson he's no right Kavanaugh
you know what I mean we love Jordan
we're dunking on them on a weekly basis
no you're you're absolutely right but I
think during covid we got him a little
bit harder yeah but these days well I
mean I don't know they're involved in
stake and all that stuff I mean yeah
obviously
and now the jerking the dog off but here
let's let's watch so this is my question
though my question is like he's been a
long time fan that's true like I'm not
even gonna die oh hey I'm not gonna even
deny that yeah I mean the first reaction
I made to what their content was a long
ass time ago before they were even big
they did the fake pizza delivery
prank where the person would like I
don't forget I don't remember but they'd
be like yo this tip's not good enough
and they would smash the pizza on the
porch or something that's dude they were
literally on the side of the proletariat
on that
they were saying like there's there's a
Earnest lesson right there at the heart
of that commentary it's social
commentary it's class Dynamics they're
talking about how delivery drivers are
underfunded and exploited okay okay okay
yeah no they were they were very
different back then yeah milk should
have stayed true to their [ __ ] Roots
some of their pranks were funny but
like they did this one now I think
you're going too far the the coke prank
was legitimately fun well I don't know
dude I've never watched a single P I've
only seen these guys when they did the
podcast with Andrew Tate they did a
couple different podcasts like one with
like Donald Trump I watched those and
that's it
but somewhere somewhere in the mech
um
they became like the milk boys which is
where by the way full send podcast the
Beast baby yeah Mr beastman on there Mr
Beast is coming on my podcast too so he
is yeah
good for you didn't reach out to me
no I reached out to him no you did yeah
because I saw him go on uh Cody's but
he's doing are you giving side long
glances
no Olivia was saying we should invite
him yeah yeah what if it says no why
would he say no what if he ghosts me
what why would that happen he he's very
he's a very kind individual very cordial
and he's been on the show before he's
been a guest on the podcast yeah I know
I saw yeah but do you think because he's
doing so many podcasts maybe it's like I
mean how much is there to talk about you
know but you think people are still
looking for Mr Beast
oh Mr Beast doesn't get views uh no no
way nobody somebody somebody's looking
for the biggest YouTuber in the world
if those words came your mouth
I want to have them on uh because I
think it'll be worse for my algorithm
I'm trying to not worry I'm trying to
make it harder for myself I'm feeling um
I'm feeling rejected because he's doing
everyone in the podcast
in L.A I think people are reaching out
to him and that's why he's doing it and
you're too big time to reach out to him
personally I'm not too big time
um speaking of podcast guess yeah
can you put me in contact with Bill Burr
I can't believe I'm doing this are you
[ __ ] serious
uh we we have it in the dock the clip so
we it's coming up oh but you want to
talk to Bill Burr because I saw his take
that was awesome he has so many like
that I've been a massive Die Hard
billboard for a very long time don't
even explain it's my dream yeah he's my
number one dream guess like people are
asking me because mine too
people were asking me like
Dua Lipa or Bill Burr is your podcast
guys Bill Burr unconditionally yeah
absolutely dude I'm I he was my dream a
good podcast with him after right oh you
know about it he knows velor yeah I know
the second one was great nobody thinks
nobody remembers the second one yeah
well this is how you can prove that the
second one was great by you know I'll
put you in touch with Bill are we in
touch with him oh Billy [ __ ] tits yeah
it was his agent that it was set up
through
it was so long ago it he might not have
the same person but we can try but also
I mean you're friends with a lot of
people in his Circle I'm sure you could
get a hold of him through like Bobby or
something last time it was Bert who put
me in touch can ask a bird oh yeah there
you go contact let's try the con that
first Contact first okay
all right that is my dream I would love
to talk I would like to see you guys
talk shop yeah it's like Donald Trump
just don't Flinch bro just Donald Trump
no I don't what do you mean Flinch I'm
just saying Spielberg no I they'll
destroy your [ __ ] life bro if you
hesitate
I I mean I you're gonna be on
antidepressants by the end of the year I
guarantee it
I don't know I've actually never watched
the original one oh so I don't know I
just remember like the memes on it you
know what it's honestly it's not as bad
as it's overblown it's it's it's cringe
but it's not like the worst [ __ ]
thing it wasn't my greatest interview by
any means I didn't think it's bad at all
I've rewatched them all ah well maybe I
I mean that's Bill any show he goes on
that's how it is I think he roasts
everybody exactly I think it was a
combination of it being not a good
interview I was very anxious at the time
so like when he would [ __ ] with me I was
kind of slow because it when I get
anxious it gives like brain fog and it's
just kind of hard to do the show
combined with the fact that I think
everybody was starting to turn on me on
the internet and so people like keemstar
and all those folks turned it into like
some big thing and yeah they do have the
capacity to to run that outrage machine
to the [ __ ] ground yeah that's yeah
which is ironic because I don't think
Bill Byrne knows or gives a [ __ ] about
any of that stuff no he's like extremely
offline no of course not part of the
reason why he doesn't
he's not one of those [ __ ] comedians
who can't shut the [ __ ] up about cancel
culture and like crying about it or
whatever he is maybe I've only won yeah
that's part of the reason why I've
maintained my position like yeah sure
he's gonna have some bad takes every now
and then no one is like super
politically apt right but he is so
[ __ ] good for
first of all he's from Boston okay yeah
the fact that he's not dropping hard R's
and and you know calling everybody the
the Q word is a pejorative not as like a
descriptive term wait what's the key
word it's just queer can be a a
pejorative if you're from Boston
like if you're even if you are queer
yourself and you're from Boston you say
it with that accent all of a sudden it's
a slur I got like I got you yeah I'm
here to suck some [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] queer
over here all of a sudden boom look at
that sounds like a slur right I got you
I got you
yeah
um I'll put you in touch I'll try to
make it happen for you buddy
uh maybe we can have a leftover I don't
know if I'm ready to face that man dude
that would be great leftovers I'll be
down to do it I'll put them out of my
head down the whole time I'll be like a
son you take this one because I don't
think he would well I mean we'll see I
don't know if he would uh want to do it
live like I wanna I wanna have like an
in-depth conversation with him
um I just I love we did it live
uh maybe one of the two was live let's
freak out let's see for leftovers yeah
yeah
I mean I'll just sit there respectfully
if he's doing the rounds he'll probably
say I don't think I don't think he is oh
well he yeah okay we'll talk the second
time we got him because the Mandalorian
was coming out and he was in that so he
was like doing press
no it was for his uh I thought his new
comedy special on Netflix I think that
was the first time all right can we
watch I just want to watch 30 seconds of
this video can we get can we do that
yeah
thank you what video yeah what were you
doing the jerk off it's break time by
the way oh [ __ ] you I mean Bradley it's
coming for you brother it's calling you
brother look at those [ __ ] thighs man
you're so right look at those this man
can say whatever he wants the moment I
see that look at the vein popping out of
his [ __ ] left calf dude he's got
vascularity out the Wazoo I mean it's
perfect that's what I'm saying you can
never say mad at a guy that jacked right
yeah no absolutely not because like I
just know the amount of dedication that
he's put into building his physique man
you could that's so gnarly you can just
see the [ __ ] man it's not very the pee
hole and everything
that's [ __ ] up
yeah put that thing away I hate that all
right let me finish this clip and then
we'll do our ad
okay
yeah so my question is like do do they
actually genuinely believe because I
know that they're smart they're smarter
than that like do they actually
genuinely believe that it was real
because I saw their reactions and they
were like I can't believe this this is
so crazy how is how not people were not
upset about this and like all these like
this is the craziest thing I've ever
heard is he's so serious it's like what
I think too they might just be just like
us where they're literally just looking
for a title and a thumbnail yeah
did you watch our video there Kyle we
indulged in that [ __ ] and I don't think
he was in the title or thumbnail because
I get [ __ ] banned if I put what they
talk about
I
I will say like in the most charitable
circumstance
the only reason why we would have uh
believed it is because Bradley Martin's
acting is so incredible I guess dude I
mean he is he is the male mayor of
street he is yeah I've heard that said
because like he is in disbelief in that
clip yeah like when this information has
dropped wait what it's not like he's
like yeah that's crazy that you do that
for sure he's just straight up he's like
what the [ __ ] yeah he's like wait
clarify for me now what are you talking
about yeah which and by the way
never once were they like oh that was
just a joke we're just kidding dude why
would you want to lie about jerking off
your dog like why would you want someone
to believe that about you as a joke
I think if you go to the comments is my
favorite part Steve was dead ass serious
Kyle clearly knows it as well Steve was
dead these are their fans yeah that
Steve was dead serious stop the cap
Steve Steve seemed dead curious can't
blame others for taking it seriously
I really was there's just damage control
can't co-sign that dog [ __ ]
I've been watching hitting up boys and
still will do it from day one when Lucas
was there Steve was cracking these types
of jokes from day one
I don't that one's in defense of him
yeah they're saying it's a joke but
Andrew Taylor the most time was joking
with these days people can't take a joke
man he see he didn't seem to be in a
joking mood that day dude was dead this
year he was dead [ __ ] serious he was
not joking bro we know when Steve is
trolling based on facial expression I
just don't I fit either of those dudes
are like
capable of being Oscar award-winning
actors you know what I mean yeah that
was my attitude too when I saw this it's
just like they're they'd have to be
comedic Geniuses
to be that dead pan I want someone to
believe that about you yeah
you know what's crazy one time I went to
the farm and I let a horse [ __ ] me in
the ass bro it was awesome yo you dead
ass
bro wait clarify clarify you got a big
ass Kong see we can't even do it we
can't do it because we're [ __ ] joking
I want people to think that I [ __ ]
animals
I can't even deadpan it like Brad was
Bradley's been [ __ ] working out extra
acting muscles I guess I don't know how
the [ __ ] you got that out yeah here's
here's Bradley saying oh it got age
restricted I wonder why
better than Selena listen to Brad's
response here okay because I'm I'm the
cool dad dude I'll be honest I didn't
see this conversation going that way but
I was I kind of like it's crazy this
[ __ ]
is dead serious I'm the cool dad you're
not on anybody
I could not tell the dog story was fake
at all Jesus it was real sounding yeah
you it was real my brother
there it is I love where we're going
down wait what yes wait one second
there's a really funny comment there
um he goes if it wasn't a Frenchie I
think he was joking but Frenchy owners
are really about this life
I love that yeah they go hard in the
[ __ ] paint for their dog penis what
the [ __ ] is this Bradley my steroids
never came in the mail and I did the
secret merch order and left the note
is this boy selling uh steroids on his
merch shop I think they're trolling yeah
yeah okay let's thank our sponsor
stamps.com and then well we've made it
through two videos I have like
we are not bro we don't not getting
anywhere in this show that's the way it
goes
best Baltic show in the world folks
we're learning all kinds I want to try
not to over prepare the first the first
couple months we were doing the show I
would have like a four-page dock in
there and we get to maybe like five
percent of it
if you pee I get I get your percentage
[Music]
just kidding hey guys you know what I
love stay
stamps we love stamps there's nothing
more
American than stamps am I right
William you are actually right about
that thank you goes all the way back to
them Pony Express we used to ride them
Pony
um
it's a good wholesome sponsor if you're
a business owner you know just how
important it is to be ready for this
insane holiday season and if you haven't
started preparing for the chaos you're
already falling behind luckilystamps.com
has everything you need to make your
life a whole lot easier it's a 24 7 post
office that you can access from anywhere
no lines no traffic no hassle
stamps.com is the One Stop Shop for all
your shipping and mailing needs listen
to this with inflation On The Rise every
dollar counts protect your margin with a
major discount on USPS and UPS rates up
to 86 percent
are you freaking kidding me dude
unbelievable
it's a stress-free solution you know you
can use stamps.com to print postage
whatever uh wherever your businesses are
mailing to and all you need is a
computer and a printer
sorry it says wherever you do your
business okay uh your girlfriend uses
stamps I understand that she loves it
she does yeah use it for her business
and gets those fat discounts the
discounts are great they provide you
with a free digital scale you plug that
in
you weigh it then you print the postage
put it on leave it in front of your
house or in your mailbox and they come
and get it it's like bada [ __ ] Bing
Bob is your uncle
unbelievable you save it's more
convenient I mean it's a no-brainer
think about it you don't don't even have
to think about it so go ahead
get ahead of the holiday season
and get started with stamps.com sign up
with promo code leftovers for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code leftovers thank you
to stay yeah thank you Stan we love you
do you guys have you guys have sponsors
on the beer and no are you trying to get
sponsors no you don't want sponsors no
how you you guys plan on making it we
have a patreon oh okay with uh
we shoot the pot you would know if you
ever came on the podcast the guest Ethan
oh come on I'll come on um I have kids
that's my excuse for everything yeah and
also I told you already we have like
only flattering angles only top down
oh yeah so you will you will never get
caught slipping um yeah we do a we have
a patreon uh patreon.com furand where we
have
I think we have a bunch of patrons we
have a lot of patrons now why don't you
do sponsors oh I just got suspended
that's crazy let's see bowling and
harassment
or Tick Tock is so bad with that man
every single time I've gone live I guess
I did a blacksmithing stream
and in that blacksmith's dream I'm using
power tools and I don't even do anything
like crazy
immediately The Tick Tock that we posted
got tagged for harmful activity oh tick
tock
like I get it they have this this
Monumental task of moderating an ungodly
on such a [ __ ] job bro
such a [ __ ] like it is it is the most
easily like weaponizable uh platform
like we're we're Mass
like people will just Auto people will
just Spam
uh report and you're done the thing is
though because of the nature of it
like I saw a dude's [ __ ] like a straight
boner on my feed
and then [ __ ] are you looking at that
that came up on your feet Ethan listen I
don't know but that it came up
apparently something maybe you've been
you've been eating too much bull penis
bro I've on Tick Tock live I've seen
people straight up [ __ ] like that's
why I mean it's kind of it's insane I've
I heard that I didn't see this video but
I heard someone talking about it that
like last week there was a video going
viral of some
uh like gorilla agents playing soccer
with someone's human head and it's real
it's like a real video that had like 700
000 likes on Tick Tock so who the [ __ ]
liking that it's I I know they're
[ __ ] like oh my God the the narcos
are playing soccer with someone's head I
love that Cliff I think it's just a
shock it's a chocolate you just go ah
and then you like it I mean it's the
same with how he's prolapse and it's got
a lot of likes
it's just a sh it's like this is on Tick
Tock let's go you know what I mean
oh this camera's up yeah you have it on
my it shows up like it's in front of me
oh yeah here drink it I can't I can't
reach it I love gamer Subs this is
BlackBerry oh it's too far by the way
you should do ads why not I I can put
you in touch with my peeps I don't want
to oh come on we might in the future but
um I have a patreon I'm I'm happy I love
the subscription model dude so shouts
out the [ __ ] twitch for ruining that
that's real nice of you guys but yeah no
I I think it's the it's the best way to
do it obviously everybody else has
different methods memberships I prefer I
prefer membership uh Revenue model over
everything
okay if you ever change your mind let me
know I got good people yeah uh let's try
to actually watch some stuff Trump is
going wild with these oh Trump is gonna
go so wild
Ron death santis uh Florida's governor
and Google dude he came out during the
hurricane
this [ __ ] fit goes [ __ ] hot
Ethan you're so jealous bro I'm
admitting he fills in those booths like
nobody has else's business man also
tucked in that's a fupa Warrior he hides
it well but yeah he's pretty
foopalicious yeah
he does he does but who the [ __ ] gave
him those white boots dude dude whoever
did genius did you see the non-edited
version because this is the edited photo
have you seen the non-edited photo yeah
I got it right here
no
oh no Mr DeSantis step away from the
bull [ __ ] wait so what's the uh what is
oh the one with the high heels yeah the
real one because that's what he wore
yeah you guys and he [ __ ] slayed he
did slay he slayed yeah big sleigh he's
got a good step he's got a future that
uh death santis
um also death Santos was in a new Chad
versus virgin meme oh I love this one so
much especially because we can look at
this on YouTube and I won't get banned
why would you get banned on Twitch I
don't know take a look at what my man is
wearing on the left side what is that
crap oh Florida Cracker and Biden's uh
mixing it up with Mr cracker over here
yeah white guys from Florida call
themselves crackers my license plate
says cracker cracker
oh [ __ ] twitch bro and what I don't
know why is for death Santa is so sad
not a Chad like Joe Joseph cracker Biden
yeah
I thought he looks like he's crying and
the way his butt his what's with his
body language he's like lurked over like
a freaking he looks exactly like the
meme it's yeah unbelievable
this is a hilarious thing wait is this
the uneditive one you're talking about I
wish
the Cowboys wait I think I know which
one you're talking about Rhonda Saints
can't do a dead drop death drop
yes dude I love this
he looks great he looks great nobody can
rock high heels through a wreckage like
he can yeah it's hard it's not easy I
respect it not easy
it's always just so so funny that like
Floridians are like yeah that's my
Governor gonna vote for him again love
that guy dude that's will be Prez
I don't say that don't forget don't put
that evil out there not after this photo
dude that would mean this is the end of
him mean my man Trump is dead okay right
oh rest in peace over Trump's dead
[ __ ] body and you know my ass is
voting for him in the Republican
primaries and the general election
going all the way with him hell yeah I
thought this was legit Photoshop though
because it's like slightly out of focus
and just his body language is
unbelievable there Chad versus virgin
Virgin uh DeSantis there so that's I
mean Joe even has his arm the same arm
as the meme around the woman it's like
uncanny
I think part of the reason why
part of the reason why that that he's
upset visibly is because like
he's in this unique predicament where
like he has to get federal funds
you know for the uh hurricane disaster
relief yes okay
and
for but that's that's uh that means that
he has to like play ball with Joe Biden
and like act nice
you know what I mean and that that's
going to look bad in the Republican uh
primaries where he tries to defeat
Donald Trump but you'll lose anyway and
I mean it is a little embarrassing to
ask for federal aid
when you're basically so much of the
funds fully against too much of the
funds to save the Venezuelans by sending
them Martha's Vineyard instead of
Florida from Texas yeah Mr Joe Biden we
may have misappropriated some funds we
sent some of them immigrants over to
Martha's Vineyard remember they were not
in Florida which is like
this the key component is he took
Floridian funds
to ship 50 Myron's in Texas to Martha's
Vineyard yeah yeah that's a good that's
taxpayer money right there boy
um
my kids can't have free lunch [ __ ] that
yeah your kids need to learn how to pick
themselves up buy those [ __ ]
bootstraps they need to learn how to be
productive start selling hey you know
how everyone shits on California first
date to offer guaranteed free school
lunches to kids
that's communism that's disgusting God
help us I mean that is insane that
that's an achievement but there it is
California we're the only one issue a
trigger warning before you see some
commy [ __ ] like that that's why
Marjorie Taylor green is hunting hogs
out there stop communism
or kill those launch ladies no are those
Mr dog [ __ ] more on [ __ ] thank
you X you see are the free meals the the
like the MREs that we used to get in
middle school I think it's better than
MREs okay uh barely probably I mean
apparent some people like MRE so I'm not
even going to accept those listen I'm
not it's food it's food food's food it's
great that's a great thing that they're
doing I just I I had the cafeteria food
growing up and don't have the Fondest
Memories there's no such thing as a free
launch okay these kids what are they
learning in school sharing is caring
there's no such thing as a free lunch
and also sharing is not caring that is
it's communism you would say yeah it's
communism and we're and quite frankly
I'm tired of acting like it's not that
is so [ __ ] perfect that is exactly
what he would think about that you know
if their kids weren't if their parents
weren't such lazy bums they'd be able to
afford to buy lunch for themselves now
if you're not working no no they're
freeloaders they're Free Riders these
kids these children back in the day in
the 17th century they would be using
their tiny little fingers to make sure
that they hem and Sue right that's what
the Indonesian children are doing and
that's precisely why Indonesia is
lapping us um they're destroying us we
need to abolish all child labor laws
okay these kids need to earn their own
lunches they're freeloading they are a
burden on society it's time they earn
their own carry their own weight why do
American children get so pampered they
need to be productive Hard Times make
hard men are whatever you know you heard
what Jordan Peterson said yeah good
friend yeah exactly hard men like me Ben
Shapiro I am a hard man
by the way correction California offers
free breakfast and lunch that's
disgusting you're telling me that they
all dude what the [ __ ] oh ew what they
should be doing instead is places like
Philadelphia where they like literally
will brand you if you don't actually pay
your lunch debt or like force you to go
to the cafeteria I remember
um psychotic when I was in elementary
school my parents never gave me money
for lunch
and so
um there was times where you could go to
the lunch lady and say hey my I forgot
the money can you loan me and she keeps
a ledger and then if if you don't pay
back your and I'm I'm talking about like
five-year-olds and if you don't pay back
the money they stop serving your ass
lunch and they start calling your
parents shaking you down and stuff it's
awesome it is one of the most psychotic
things I've ever encountered in my
entire life that like the wealthiest
Nation on Earth will leave children
unattended without food when they need
it for their survival and of course
millions of children actually rely on
the school system to get their only
nutritious meal so there's a there's
another component to that well there's
there's so much scarcity in a country
that has a surplus of food America has a
surplus of food supply if if these kids
were so hungry they would be at the
HomeTown Buffet garbage and and it's 52
there now there's a lot of good food
there that goes to waste and these kids
they're freeloading they don't need a
free lunch they need to take a trip to
Hometown Buffet and that's those fat Fox
if they can spare some crumbs
by the way you like this
I do it's like insanely accurate
I cannot believe what I'm seeing
he is the virgin
Maria it was so bad I've just never seen
someone do the Virgin walk so perfectly
in real life that's that's the weird
part about this he's just like
yeah it's pretty crazy but you know
people talk a lot of [ __ ] to California
and that they got high taxes and all
this so we're the only state that has
guaranteed maternity leave
disgusting and guaranteed uh meals for
kids I'm not [ __ ] I'm so mad I'm
moving to Texas where kids start
disgusting I want to save 10 on my taxes
so the kids of Texas can starve as long
I mean that's what they're doing no I
mean look let's be real okay you know
what I'm not gonna complain that's
better than nothing let's keep it a
stack okay it's not like California is
this wonderful communist Haven there are
some good policies there are some good
Provisions but this is also another like
liberal Safe Haven and I mean liberal as
a in a bad way I mean it is a pejorative
and what I mean by that is that they
have had a lot of Charter School
initiatives out here as well
um and private school costs have
skyrocketed private schools have
exploded in popularity here as well Tech
uh California also has a pretty strong
uh teachers union that's part of the
reason why
um the the the uh you know utla uh is is
a relatively influential organization
and relatively influential Union which
is why they like want to undermine
Public Schools as best as possible
so there's a lot of issues there as well
every time you advocate for a charter
school and Democrats do this all the
time as well remember that you are
basically saying let's take funds away
from our already crippled Public Schools
uh and and give it to Charter Schools
instead that are unaccountable and uh
and and have way way higher rates of
failure than public schools do across
the board and they sometimes even close
in the middle of the school season
without telling anybody really love that
for them yeah yeah the charter schools
wasn't a thing when I was a kid or maybe
it was starting it was starting to
become a thing 90s is when it popped
they'll [ __ ] off I never heard such so
gross so disgusting it's a big
conversation it happened the middle
school that I went to became one so like
it they renamed it and everything it's
like a totally different School than the
one that I went to Growing Up fun fact
Amy Klobuchar actually made pizza
advocated for pizza to be declared a
vegetable because of the Tomato content
it wasn't that base this is a tomato
is pizza is a vegetable Papa John agrees
Papa John Pizza is actually very
nutritious well I'm going to be eating
lots of vegetables tonight my friend
according to Amy Gorbachev status
all right let's watch this we're back
we're on the Fox News
now apparently Scooby-Doo fans of Velma
which is the short-haired orange sweater
well it turns out Velma likes girls
no way when will they stop when will
they stop with this boat culture and
let's be honest I mean listen I have a
pretty good gaydar
we all knew
we all knew do you have a pretty good
guitar you just kind of dropped that out
there like for no re like I think I have
a pretty good game I have a good gaydar
why do you think I have a bad hater you
think that I just I don't necessarily
think you have bad but I don't know all
these gay people walking around me and I
don't know
I'm not a spot I felt gay
I felt that note
you told me
oh that's the [ __ ] egg he's so funny
yeah but so velma's I mean listen
velma's gay Color Me surprised what like
she got herself like a girlfriend or a
romantic interest I don't know I haven't
seen it yeah this is gay and interracial
which is like a double whammy for her
they were baiting him with this one like
we can't stop this
so anyway
um not just Typecast lesbians or
anything I mean listen I didn't make the
cartoon they did don't blame me yeah in
the words of Bill Burr I don't know what
a lesbian looks like gun to my head no
idea I'm right
so here they are in Fox News as you know
taking on the uh biggest and most
important issues of the day
here they are
on Scooby-Doo you know my problem with
this is and we've seen it in it's been
creeping in increments beloved
characters of childhood no they're not
allowed the the adult values are being
imposed on them the Lord there was a
Winnie the Pooh movie came out first of
all brother you are on Fox News talking
about Winnie the Pooh okay you are an
unserious person that's number one okay
number two being gay is not an adult
value it's just like a a default
position that you could be you know what
I mean it's not also velma's like a
grown ass person like how old nobody's
like nobody's like wow I can't believe
they have straight relationships in
Scooby-Doo like well you know what I
mean I'd get his point if maybe it was
like um Rugrats
evening rugrat like even then it's just
they use I'm against gay rub right they
usually won't do that anyway but they'll
like don't think they'll make like a lot
of the Beloved childhood characters be
like kind of gay I mean will you come
out now against gay Rugrats
sure no gay but no gay babies no gay
babies but but only only with the
concession that there's no straight
relationships either no straight babies
yeah no all babies are straight God damn
you they born straight they learn to be
gay but you see but you see my point
right like that's the main point of
contention here is that like being gay
is somehow different than being straight
and that it's like uh you're you know
you're you live your life until you're
18 years old and then once you turn 18
you're like okay I'm assigned one of
these two things like gay or straight
and Rick Perry was like you know
whatever
he chose he chose one of them he won't
tell so uh uh Velma is apparently
according to Lord 16. that's an
appropriate age I feel like to
have a sexual identity I just I don't
think there's an appropriate age I think
like if we're talking about it if we're
talking about it on terms like uh
of like whether someone is gay or
straight or whatever the point is no one
ever considers the relationship that
Tommy Pickles had with the with the
blonde uh baby right like that's not
that that's just normal that's default
so no one is like well that's kind of
weird that there's like a relationship
Factor there right so that's the point
that that that's the point I'm always
making which is like
you think because it's gay it's somehow
different and implies like immediately
implies sex
right it's not nine months
but however Fox News disagrees with you
obviously you're wrong the adult values
are being imposed on them Laura there
was a Winnie the Pooh movie that just
came out not long ago where Winnie the
Pooh and piglet are serial killers this
one really I was like how why do you
first of all that sounds based and dope
when this first came out Steve will do
it was like please Scooby-Doo please
Scooby-Doo and Shaggy what is going on
is there a love Arc there come on please
jerking off finally someone for Steve
will yank it
about to forget all about those Scooby
Snacks yeah coming straight to Daddy
Steve I think one of the weirdest things
that they came out and said I don't
remember at what point they came out
with this but like they said Shaggy
doesn't smoke weed I was like get the
[ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
get out of here yeah okay bro
you tell me shaggy doesn't [ __ ] his dog
get out of here no that's not what he's
saying I don't think they do that okay
Elijah you know no you don't know what
goes on uh here let's watch the poo and
piglet are serial killers because uh
Winnie the Pooh entered public domain
there there he is and he's a serial
killer with piglet you can't make that
sound not cool as hard as you try it's
it's fine it's fine there's nothing
wrong why is he mad about that yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's trying to
he's really trying hard to make this
into a thing the the horror of all of
this is the horror who didn't create
these characters are manipulating them
and maiming them in the public
imagination that's my biggest objection
here this guy is against free speech
he's like I want to maintain the
intellectual property of Winnie the Pooh
I don't think that you should be able to
edit anybody's content or art or even to
criticize them in the public sphere
unless it's me criticizing other
people's derivative works because that's
allowed because I'm conservative there
you heard it this man is against Free
Speech interesting take there Fox News
it's just so weird like if they made a
[ __ ] horror flick with Vinnie the
pooch I didn't even know existed right
yeah they did okay like that's clearly
not for children my man what the [ __ ]
are you talking about yeah it's like
it's rated R I'm pretty sure yeah what
he is so weird get to the history of
Velma the New York Times said she's
canonically a lesbian well when Hannah
Barbera created her it was a spin-off of
a character on Dolby Gillis okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna put it out there my man
my man's giving uh queer code that's
what I mean yeah the way he said she's
canonically a lesbian okay bro like be
your authentic self man stop I felt gay
well fousey yeah
yeah I said Vinnie instead of uh Winnie
I'm Turkish we don't have the we don't
have the letter W chat I'm a reading
chat the Germans do that too yeah I I
sometimes [ __ ] that up okay you guys
call me English is my second language
y'all don't have dubs what no wonder
turkey's a walking L because you guys
don't have dubs what do you mean no we
oh oh yeah I was gonna say no they have
dubbed movies sorry yeah sorry after all
the Turkish fans out there just a little
joke there for y'all thank you kind of
Applause yeah I mean listen I'm not
gonna put it on this man but he
definitely gives us some anyway Hannah
Barbera created her it was a spin-off of
a character on Dobby Gillis from the 50s
it was this is a real Far Cry okay there
were no gays in the 50s dude he's like
uh famously an era without any
homosexual activity of course yes uh
back in the good old days where you
stayed in the closet it was a spin-off
of a character on Dobby Gillis from the
50s it was this is a I love it he kind
of he kind of loses her there
yeah
from the 50s it was yeah even Laura
and I think you gotta chill the [ __ ] out
bro you know a little too much yeah
she's like you're being sus you're being
susp bro
right that's
that's a what does Scooby-Doo oh
absolutely
a boy
what right that's a boys cartoon I don't
think the girls oh you're not even
allowed to say that anymore sorry wait
why wait no you are allowed to say that
but it's stupid why would that be a boys
car what
what decides that it's a boys cartoon
these people have one [ __ ] routine
and they do it all day all the time they
must because there's making comments
that they make all the time like it was
a boys cartoon oh well I'm not allowed
to say that like they [ __ ] do let me
just make that joke all day non-stop
uh Scooby-Doo seems kind of gender
neutral to me yeah
but I don't know there it is guys uh
Winnie the Pooh and Velma are a
what's this I have something to show you
oh great what happened
oh wait sorry I'm gonna fix the audio
uh oh I stand Peewee I wonder if that
was just like a homophobia thing because
that happened back in the day when
people were like gay people are demons
not gay it wasn't in a theater like that
this was a erotic dude last week when
you correctly uh incorrectly called Paul
rubin's gay I think he is gay
okay question baslerman
show me a picture
oh interesting oh anything about you
just say it based on the name alone
they said the name alone and I have no
contacts I'm gonna say uh no okay I'm
gonna give you oh that's a that's a
spicy take okay
Elvis movie what Elvis movie Moulin
Rouge I believe Phantom of the Opera as
well Romeo and Juliet Romeo and Juliet
Romeo and Julia yeah I don't know what
you're talking about right now this is
boss Lerner famous director I literally
don't know who that is Great Gatsby did
The Great Gatsby movie yeah I've never
seen any of these movies I know what
they are but I don't know who the [ __ ]
boss Lerman
he is uh he claims he is not gay his
name's baz
yeah b-a-z where's that man what's the
origin oh this man's gay
that's [ __ ] up you said that because
he's not gay or bi
come on bro
I'm not gay no more I love this because
like the first thing that you surge if
you look up like boslerman gay is like
an lgbt.com article or something where
it's like 10 celebrities you didn't know
were straight that's so obvious that's
funny yeah look at these two come on
I know he's the actor in the movie this
this conversation seems inappropriate to
be to be this is one of those
conversations where like
this man is [ __ ] one of those
conversations
uncharitable uncharitable uh Ethan Klein
uh aunties will say that you're being
homophobic but like virtually every gay
person would be like yeah the dudes come
on
I know he's smoking on big dogs there's
no way that guy never touched a dick in
his life like okay let's say let's not
debate gay it's like has he touched a
dick before in his life
I mean you don't have he's just you know
I I I'm the man who has that game not
even because of uh his outfits or
anything but because he made literally
every [ __ ] popular Broadway musical
yeah
like every popular Hollywood rendition
of a Broadway musical has been made by
this man there is no [ __ ] shot you
are like you know let's see is he
married yeah he's married to a woman
married to a woman you say yeah
I think she was a uh set designer on one
of the first uh things that he has I
don't think he has any reason to lie I
mean I don't know anything about him so
okay shout out to uh baz who is straight
straight King it's out here the man is
straight and I think we need a pride
minute to follow up because I feel just
a little bit gross having speculated on
this guy's sexuality something that I
would never do unless I was with his son
who egged me on all right that was my
fault you guys can get mad at me if you
want be like Hassan is homophobic but I
do want to say to baz
or whoever's listening if you are in the
closet it's time to come out and be a
real authentic song I mean take your own
time obviously of course you know do it
in a healthy way but uh you don't take
too long you will live how old is your
life you know what I mean you will live
you will live a much healthier life uh
when you are surrounded by people who
accept you and even if you don't have
people who even if you feel like you
don't have people who accept you in your
immediate vicinity uh there are always
going to be good people that will uh
welcome you with open arms Liberace used
to sue people who called him gay yeah
that's awesome bro yeah who would think
that it that you know the judge would be
like bro come on
that's all that's the old but wait bring
back Prime minute I don't want to
where's the music well actually Prime
minutes over in three two we can get
everyone start them private I wasn't
sure if Dan started oh yeah
wait we're gonna do two minutes of Pride
well okay stop don't try this important
so all my LGBT kings and queens and days
and Dems and everything in between and
all things in the world
you are beautiful the way you are you
were born perfect don't let anybody tell
you the way you were born weren't
perfect don't let anybody convince you
that what you're doing is wrong morally
wrong is anything you are a gay king or
queen or Prince or them per
oh damper that's so good don't let a
single [ __ ] bring you down for
how you were born
stay strong I know it's not always easy
to come go through this world as a as
being a homosexual or trans
but you know what man live your best
life in spite of them despite them yeah
go into my head can't tell you boss
lerman's gay or not
nope and this message is directly to
buzz
and pause
oh I don't have my ex because we're on
the leftover setup but
it's over back in the club you freak
what
okay minute five minutes over his song
okay listen up guys back in the closet
yo come on
let's say our real opinions God damn
that was hard these goddamn gays I was
out there sweating like Rick Perry in a
bath house I tell you what man
I go to them churches that are no gays
well I took them out the door I say is
you gay boy gave him a smell give him a
little peck on the mouth and see if he
liked it or not yeah sometimes I like to
do that too you know give them a little
handshake dick shake they'll dick shake
to find out if it weren't around me when
I knew hard when I grab the when I grab
a man's [ __ ] I see if it moves it'll get
a little hard there and if it moves I
know I'm the man gay yeah I grab myself
for thousands of [ __ ] by now bud mm-hmm
you just got to make sure always make
sure that there are no no you know no
gay people around you got to kiss them
first it's the Holy Spirit you know
sometimes a little little tongue bath
you know what I'm saying just give a
little Peck oh absolutely not you got to
put in enough effort to get it moving to
get it chubbed up that's how you know
that's how you really know it's good
absolutely see you ever tasted semen
it's like another kind of milk okay okay
let's move on we got stories we got so
many stories oh we have like 13 minutes
left so whatever
okay
yo by the way oh by the way show this
guy is suing you for calling him gay
the judge be like bro
that's not liable
you you chose to wear that wear that
but there it is enough back in the
closet I don't want to talk about I
don't want to hear from you gays anymore
today I am not gay keep it to yourself
and ban the pride flap All Right Moving
On
Bill Burr the base socialism take I
gotta say even I I know Bill is like
he's pretty based like he even brought
it to Joe Rogan when Joe was going
anti-vaxx and all this [ __ ] and it's
you're so right because the most hacky
thing I hear comedians doing and they
all do it it's like time to move on get
some new material is like cancel culture
you can't say this everyone's trying to
count and I'm like I'm like dude even if
I agreed with what you're saying it's so
hacky you all been telling the same joke
for 10 years like no that's the thing is
like the the dismissal of cancer culture
is a universal value pretty much where
like nobody likes it and everybody does
it right Republicans do it all the time
uh your boy me I've been canceled a
million times over Ethan's been canceled
a million times over by the right
absolutely um I've talked about this so
[ __ ] much and it's just it's just so
whack to constantly complain about it
constantly [ __ ] complain about it he
is uh Bill Burr is actually uh you know
kind of destroyed Bill Maher on it too
uh on on like cancel culture [ __ ] where
he went on uh Bill Maher's show
and and openly told him like oh what
you're you're not gonna get what you
want out of me in this in this
conversation he cares he is pretty
incredible even though he he completely
mentally uh
even though he basically brought my life
crumbling down uh uh next to me uh I
still love him still and he is a one of
a kind here he is on Joe Rogan just to
set us up
he [ __ ] had that kind of impact on
you that's crazy bro
I wouldn't say more it's complicated I
think there was a lot going on in my
life at the time
I walked on the street with a mask on
let's not start this job this
[ __ ] it's so hard to get over
Joe Rogan is he's he doesn't want people
to walk around with masks outside
like why does that bother you but okay
okay let's get started I don't want to
start this [ __ ] I'm not going to sit
here with no medical degree listening to
you with no medical degree with an
American flag behind you smoking a cigar
acting like we know what's up better
than the CDC walked on the street with a
mask oh he goes in on him but yeah he's
I mean but it's so true the thing that I
really love about Bill Burr is that
look comedians uh
danced on this like very fine line of
doing cultural critique
and uh and also just making jokes you
know what I mean like making light of
serious subjects
and for that reason I think you need to
have a really deep understanding of the
subject matter that you're covering
that's why Dave Chappelle is brilliant
and and still the the you know number
one comedian when it comes to talking
about his own experiences uh white
supremacy uh Black Culture these sorts
of things
um but then
definitely Mrs DeMarco and talking about
trans issues because he just does not
have an understanding does not care and
is just basically doing the hackies
material
yeah he's just basically doing the
hackiest material possible which is
pointing at trans people and going
that's weird right lol come on laugh
with me that's weird like if your
material about trans people in your 20
million dollar special is identical to
like you know a Reddit comment that's
crazy that's you're not the greatest
comedian of all time what the [ __ ]
you're you're well he's he's stuck in
the cancel culture thing it's like you
got to move past that and the same yeah
the same goes for King's culture as well
where it's like yeah everyone's annoyed
by it there's a lot of hypocrisy in it
because plenty of people who are doing
the cancellation have plenty to be
canceled over themselves because human
beings are imperfect right um
but uh you know Bill Bill's made some
jokes about it but ultimately I think
the reason why I love him is because he
has a way to describe
very complex issues like American
imperialism or you know the the
contradictions that you experience under
capitalism in the most like sports guy
Bostonian way you possibly could in that
kind of demeanor where he's just like
very short he's just like yeah this suck
this [ __ ] sucks this is stupid that's
good that's a good impression yeah you
like that Monday Morning podcast is on
Monday
um
let's check this out
uh socialism
I bill you redheaded [ __ ]
I really appreciate the bluntness of
that how how are you
um last week you mentioned
uh you don't know why people demonize
socialism
um I was really taken aback at that
statement oh Jesus Christ every country
that has tried socialism has failed
and it's responsible for tens of
millions of deaths all right so would
you say capitalism is working I love
that and it is not uh you know when like
what is it like 99 of the wealth isn't
like [ __ ] two percent of the people's
hands all of these tent cities you're
telling me this is working you don't
think capitalism is responsible for tens
of millions of deaths
[Music]
um
everything that he just said I have said
a million times over it is crazy to me
that he's just like
what a I mean what an incredible thing
to hear from a dude from [ __ ] Boston
okay an old white guy from Boston come
on dude there's another joke that
reminds me he did the same thing during
the church Scandal like they brought him
on some Morning Show they're like do you
really think it's appropriate to be
making these jokes you are about the
church
they like kind of Blindsided him he's
like he he's like you think it was
appropriate what they did yeah you
should learn about what they did he's
smart
um and
yeah I'm I'm saying it [ __ ] it he's in
his George Carlin era all right that's
what that's I'll say it I think when
he's spitting his George Carlin [ __ ]
he's not he needs to I hope he goes
further with it but yeah
yeah and most recently Venezuela have
tried or right now are socialist
countries um as far as I know whatever
Cuba was trying to do we prevented them
from doing with a [ __ ] embargo or
whatever the hell we did not [ __ ]
with them for 60 years when I heard that
I lost my [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like what a lot of people do is you look
at your own country through glasses the
same way you look at your own sports
team like oh my team doesn't cheat come
on how close they're done
it's so close okay look all I'm saying
is what he just dropped about Cuba is
100 accurate okay this embargo is
completely unjustifiable it is
completely inhumane it is collective
punishment on the Cuban people that did
not deserve it and the only reason why
it happened was because we funded the
Batista regime which was a dictatorship
that was incredibly brutal far worse
than the Cuban Revolution infinitely
worse than the Cuban Revolution and when
they lost we immediately were like all
right [ __ ] this uh you know you guys are
communist now boom embargo blockade
unacceptable okay it is a human rights
violation that other countries are too
[ __ ] to [ __ ] call out
that's number one
number two Bill Burr's assessment his
analysis here is not only 100 correct
but it also goes against the grain
99.9 of commentators in the mainstream
uh in the in the political uh ecosystem
will never say what he's saying here
which is incredible to me it's true and
yet most of the people who are the
politics understanders of the world that
go on MSNBC and whatever will never
bring that up
that you'll never hear it because it
goes against our propaganda and he goes
further into it he even talks about
manufacturing consent it's just it's
brilliant it is very surprising I love
it I hope more more this bill more we
love it we love to see a woke King
Bostonian King bringing it to the people
and he sent it such stark contrast to
literally all of his comedian friends
who still will not shut the [ __ ] up
about cancer culture as you correctly
noted we love you Bill
despite what you did to me
um uh Laura
Trump who
this is the wife of like the [ __ ] of the
worst Trump son Eric should we go
through this quickly and then do a brief
note on Herschel Walker okay so that's
way bigger
oh this one's short let's just watch it
I think it's so funny Laura Trump
literally recorded this and posted it
online I mean how [ __ ] psychotic can
you be
that's just Florida activity though he's
crying that's Florida activity what do
you mean
recording yourself and your children
crying during a hurricane is the most
Florida thing you could do this is the
most man of the people moment for the
trumps I swear to God but if your kid
stops starts crying you don't you stop
recording right and you don't upload it
for sure that's not in Florida baby I
saw [ __ ] filming their mothers
drowning in the [ __ ] living room okay
but this is Laura Trump you know what I
mean I know which is that's what I'm
saying is the most flooring thing I've
ever seen authentic
well shout out there to Laura and her
son who braved
the hurricane in a Tonka trunk so there
it is [ __ ] I hope he's feeling
better to Young uh Trump there
um so you want to talk there's the we
have a right-wing dating app which we
didn't talk about
we have Herschel Walker which we didn't
get to anything man we have Elon Musk we
didn't get to any of the stories in the
headlines okay okay we got some time
Elon muswelling yeah uh let's do well we
started at 10 30. we started really late
too yeah so okay let's just get to the
main stories yeah I'm I'm down so you
want to do a Herschel Walker
we can talk about Herschel Walker we
talk about any of these things I like
all of those stories so well so Herschel
Walker is Father a friend of the show
Christian Walker right yeah I've had him
on
um he's running for Senate in Georgia
this man is severely brain damaged from
playing NF in the NFL that's not even a
joke I'm pretty sure he has brain dead
yeah he was playing when the when the
helmets were soft yeah I don't remember
whose joke that is it's a really good
one yeah his the helmets are soft just
like his uh skull now
he's down 12 points thank God
what's interesting about him is that
he's a [ __ ] idiot he's barely
literate and he came out and uh and says
he wants a born
again an abortion ban with no exceptions
no exceptions
none here's a video of him saying that
of course this is going somewhere
interesting if you guys don't know the
story where do you stand when it comes
to abortion that's something that's a
very high well you know I I am a
Christian and I Stand For Life
I stand for well I I love that I stand
for death
I'm a nautical Christian way here's the
Christian way stand for death
and I don't I don't make any excuses
about it I Stand For Life and people
always say you got any of exceptions and
I said you know
um
you know uh you know in the Bible you
know they don't talk about abortion and
in Georgia Georgia people what did he
mean by that in the Bible they don't
talk about abortion
there is uh I don't think there's any
specific verse uh dedicated to
contraceptives the only thing that you
can derive that rhetoric from is the
famous story of the dude who [ __ ] his
uh his his recently widowed brother's
wife
I forget who which Hunter Biden is his
name well Hunter Biden did the biblical
thing yes but that but the only the only
verse that is like dedicated to
contraceptives or could be interpreted
as like anti-contraceptive the one that
all these [ __ ] zealots use is uh
there's a story of a guy and his wife
and a brother okay the guy dies and then
uh and then God tells the the brother to
be like hey you need to bed the wife and
take care of her and not spill your seed
like as in the God God's literally
saying you have to nut in her you have
to [ __ ] your dead brother's wife
right and that's what they use I forget
what it's called that's it that's all
they use for all this abortion yeah
I feel like there's got to be more thou
shall not pull and pray
don't yuck it's one of the Mitzvahs too
there's the same thing about jerking off
dogs
no actually do mention yeah I think yeah
yeah no you can yeah in Judaism it's
it's perfectly fine right again it's
they stated in the 613 Mitzvahs do not
[ __ ] a beast they call it he's talking
about the bestiality I think you were
still talking about that oh you mean oh
yeah yeah except for Ben Shapiro
you're so cute he's such a price [ __ ]
like he is so he is so cucked by
Christians like oh my God it's his whole
fan base yeah it's like oh yeah I I'm
I'm one of the good ones It's gotta be
the majority of American Jews hate his
Gods because he's like I mean you know I
think Orthodox just love him or I know I
know some Orthodox Jews that are like
there's ways for reformed Jews though
yeah of course I mean the every Jew I
know [ __ ] hates his guts because he's
a lunatic well a kid's a boy or black
and I said you know
it's hard because anyone that been a
victim of crime you know my heart goes
out to them so but you having that baby
put money and adoption programs I want
to put money single fathers single moms
y'all want to find Solutions but I I'm a
Christian I believe in life
I just I can't believe I can't go over
this no exception thing like they're
doing this I'm gonna be honest it's just
women suffering and dying for no [ __ ]
reason it seems like her
seems like Herschel Walker has a very
consistent position oh wait I hope you
don't show me anything else about him
well he believes him he's a guy who
believes what he believes he's got his
convictions this is what he preaches the
Christian well unfortunately it came out
that in 2009 a woman came out and said
that Herschel asked her to get an
abortion in fact he paid for it
reimbursed her she supported these
claims with a 575 receipt
and and also a get well card so that was
nice of him
also a bank deposit receipt that include
the image of a signed 700 personal check
Walker's campaign obviously said this
woman is lying
it's a false story we're suing you
he said all you want to do is run with
stories to Target black conservatives
all you do is focus on black
conservatives
but uh gee whiz his son Christian Walker
yeah friend of the show a famous
political uh person on the right okay
he's a famous political take talker as
famous as one can get being you know
bigoted and hateful which Christian is
for sure
but also a meme in the gay community
um for his Antics he is he is definitely
uh a a you know telegenic person very
charismatic in his bigotry
um anyway he came out and and was being
serious for once and talked about how
his father Herschel Walker had abused
him and his mom they had to travel six
times run away from him he had this
video Let's watch the video can I ask
you a question this guy always seems
super rich is it from his dad yeah no he
is he is so he he drives around his
[ __ ] G-Wagon harassing Starbucks
stories dissolved so is it just like his
dad probably had to pay out his mom who
took care of him probably I'm assuming
any relationship with him no his
Christian's mom is the one is the woman
that he was married to for a long time
it's all the other ones that he okay so
Christian's mom is got a probably a big
nice settlement in the divorce
so he's got that Swag yeah so Christian
said I've stayed silent for nearly two
years as my whole life has been lied
about publicly I did one campaign event
then said I didn't want involvement
don't you dare test my authenticity
here's the full story
downplayed I stayed silent when it came
out that my father rehearsal Walker out
all these random kids across the country
none of whom he raised
and you know my favorite issue to talk
about is Father absent surprise because
it affected me that's why I talk about
it all the time but it's pretty
consistent with conservatism though only
values people pause it I was like I
would never guess that this guy has
issues no being being a one-issue guy
that has impacted you is like at the
heart of all conservative attitude like
like Dick Cheney being homophobic until
you know his daughter comes out and is
like I'm a lesbian and then he's like
okay we'll just we'll just drop that for
a little bit even though Liz Cheney
straight up what a demon was anti-gay
uh which she apologized for recently but
she was anti-gay even after everybody
knew that uh her sister was a lesbian I
see a lot of people being like Oh no way
that's his son and yeah I actually
didn't know somehow that that I know
they that absolutely is no I know I'm
just saying I didn't connect the dots
for some reason I just thought he was
like a goofball no he even looks like
him what do you mean I thought he I saw
him on Tick Tock I didn't know anything
about herself oh yeah no I always knew
you know what I mean he's a he's a
friend of the show
friend of the friend of Hashem and I
unconditionally agree with everything
he's ever said
four kids yeah be careful it's on every
time you say that I see a couple
comments in the chat it was like is this
on serious wait oh my God I'm always
sarcastic if I'm saying anything like
even remotely right wing know that I'm
I'm not Beast it happened earlier in the
episode where you said you were voting
for Trump in 2024. I had to correct it
except for that okay
I love it well actually that that's okay
yeah
I got you I mean I I do I shoot guns
guns I think guns are great you said
anything remotely Republican is highly
sarcastic I think on ownership should be
a republican value I think guns are are
fun to shoot but I think they should be
insanely regulated I think it's a
[ __ ] ridiculous notion that like
usually you can just go to a Walmart and
like pick up a [ __ ] mass murder
machine like that's psychotic ladies and
gentlemen we got him we got you buddy
you're [ __ ] I mean yeah I got myself
when I shot a [ __ ] Draco uh very
openly in front of hundreds of thousands
of [ __ ] viewers in Vegas and uploaded
to my YouTube you sounded like Hassan
pecker yeah I saw the automatic shotgun
it's [ __ ] awesome let's watch this
goddamn house raising one of them he was
out having sex with other women do you
care about family values right I have a
silent lie after lie after lie the
abortion card drops yesterday it's
literally his handwriting in the car
they say they have receipts whatever he
gets on Twitter he lies about it okay
I'm done
go off everything has been a lie
to say I'm
when you all have been calling me saying
is this true about your Dad gosh we're
not going to win Georgia this candid all
that's been you you have no so I didn't
know watch the whole thing or it's just
it's like bro you're you're putting
together the pieces right you you're on
the wrong side bro you don't have to be
Maga
yeah I mean come come to the side come
to Pride minute my friend we'll
celebrate you one minute of you I mean
he doesn't even like he has so many
funny I mean he has so many funny memes
that the the gay Twitter absolutely
loves about him being like
I'm not gay don't call me gay I just
like the [ __ ] men or get [ __ ] by men
or whatever why was he not joking though
no I mean that stuff it's just hard it's
hard he he like toes this line in in
some of his his jokes that like
a a irony poisoned leftist gay man would
absolutely uh say those exact same
things you know what I mean about like
uh I hate uh some of y'all gays you know
some of that stuff like it's so it's
it's weird but like I said he's
intelligent he's very charismatic oh
very yeah I think he's very funny I just
don't know what's what's serious or not
but this story really gets amazing when
uh it comes out
I think yesterday or a few days ago that
um
it turns out that a surprise surprise
the woman who came forward
and said this man's had an abortion He's
a hypocrite and then he goes I don't
have no idea who this is it turns out
that woman was hold on hold on before
you say that he didn't say that he went
on Sean Hannity which by the way if
you've followed the Herschel Walker
campaign like I have any time he's on
camera it's a horrible problem for the
GOP uh because he is so bad like he
demonstrably has like like degenerative
brain problems like like yeah he he has
gave all of his Charisma to his son
apparently yeah he's just like the
stiffest dude wait what do you call that
brain uh CTE yeah he definitely has CTE
but like you will never be able to
diagnose it until you know he passes
away and then they open up his brain
unfortunately that's the only medical
way to figure that out conclusively but
it does seem like he definitely I mean
he's been he's definitely had a lot of
brain trauma regardless so
he's really bad on camera he always is
the worst [ __ ] she goes on Sean Hannity
and Sean Hannity's just like trying to
do a PR move for him and he's like is
this you Herschel is this your writing
and he's like he doesn't even say no he
just goes I don't know I write a lot of
letters which was awesome it was [ __ ]
awesome he's like yeah I give a lot of
money to people I I don't know maybe I I
don't know right I didn't do that and
then they talk about his Charities or
whatever but that was great so the best
part comes when you find out the woman
who said this about him is
the mother of one of his children yeah
not some random Hussein like you might
think like Dana Dana Loach called her a
skank dude that made that clip made my
jaw drop bro yeah she is such a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] holy [ __ ] the woman who uh
registered Democrat whose year-long
relationship with Walker continued after
the abortion told The Daily Beast that
her Chief concern with revealing her
name was because she's the mother of one
of Walker's own children like I love how
he acts like I don't know who the [ __ ]
that is is she's the mother of his own
child and she wanted to protect her
family's privacy as best she could while
coming forward with the truth Walker has
publicly acknowledged the child as his
own to be fair to be fair
he might not remember like he actually
might not remember he he's like yeah
he's like drooling half the [ __ ] time
yeah on ironic they might be like oh no
I'm pro-life I guess uh I had an
abortion um I guess it's possible
I'm surprised Republicans haven't said
that like making fun of Herschel Walkers
uh like mental health is ableist and
also racist because they that would have
to be them
um uh uh admitting that this man is
severely brain damaged well he has said
it he has said that he hasn't said that
he's brain damaged but he had a new
campaign that had to come out he said
yeah I have mental health complications
that's why I uh he basically admits to
like abusing his uh doing domestic
assault
um it was like Raphael Warnock says I
did certain things and then it shows
like the headlines which is like put a
knife to her throat like literally shows
it in his own [ __ ] ad and then he
goes yeah I did you know but he never
asked why and it's because I had mental
health complications and how did I solve
that
God oh no he's gonna do it again God
ain't gonna keep that ain't God ain't
gonna stay that hand he said he says uh
yeah he says God helped him I'd even get
over his his uh did I'm gonna need more
concrete
steps even though he took it in the god
Direction just even saying like they
never asked why it just
I gotta see that it's like she was being
a real [ __ ] that day one day yeah you
know whenever I asked why Rafael never
asked was the were the Vibes [ __ ] the
baby have that I aborted that [ __ ] was
talking back to me on that day nobody
ever that is like
like that's you know that'll that'll
help him in the Georgia race I think the
Republicans be like yeah that's just
like me for real we lost me for real
I'll be alive we like that Herschel
Walker he keeps his woman in check
Ooey
here is
Dana Loesch I don't know who she is this
is the first time I've seen her but this
is she is a vile [ __ ] witch I have
never seen anything like this is so vile
bro
um
I'm sorry this is a trigger warning
honestly it's that upsetting so does
this change anything
I I mean do you want my opinion this is
her response to basically everyone being
like Oh yeah he definitely got an
abortion you're listening not a damn
thing
how many times have I said four very
important words
these four words winning is a virtue
what I'm about that's why they always
win by the way yeah winning is the only
virtue they do though they do win they
do win all the [ __ ] time all the odds
are against them they don't have the
votes they don't have the numbers but
they always win they cheat the system
they they change the dynamic on a you
know they'll do anything and I love that
for them about to say is in
no means a contradiction
or a compromise it sounds insecure
and please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point
so I don't care if Herschel Walker paid
to abort endangered baby eagles I want
control of the Senate what did she say
endangered baby eagles I mean I mean no
he he had an abortion like a perfectly
healthy baby fetus why of Eagle why any
what the [ __ ]
uh maybe that's because abortion is not
[ __ ] murder and they unironically
know that and they still cynically
repeat that talking point even though
it's technically not murder anymore when
it's like uh you know in it when it's a
when it's a product of like incestuous
rape as a matter of fact like because
they they have this like unconditionally
across the board all abortion is murder
uh line once they got what they wanted
out of the Supreme Court and they
realized there was genuine backlash to
it they were slated to over perform in
the midterms and then that all went away
you saw the Kansas vote and how it swung
in Kansas because there was a referendum
in the in the king's vote as well so
they they noticed that and they were
like oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] up and you saw
people like Blake Masters in the Arizona
Senate race for example immediately
scrubbed their website clean of all the
prior things that they had said about
how all abortion is murder
unconditionally and you shouldn't do it
and then they were like some murders are
good actually some murders is fine
abortion is murder but like we love
murder
um she thinks that a mer aborting a baby
baby eagle is worse than a fetus yes
exactly
that's exactly the point if Herschel
Walker
say what now
does this change anything
and please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point all right get on with
it so I don't care if Herschel Walker
paid to abort endangered baby eagles I
want control of the Senate
if The Daily Beast story is true
you're telling me Walker used his money
to reportedly pay
some skank for an abortion and Warnock
wants to use all of our Monies to pay a
whole bunch of skanks for abortions
and yes when they're used
she is such a vile [ __ ] witch holy
[ __ ] she's like skeleton that's straight
up that is internalized misogyny right
there man but it's wonderful because
like she's like oh yeah it's it's again
the woman's fault in this situation for
uh going and and you know breaking an
honest man who wanted to be in a [ __ ]
marriage or whatever even though he's
like a routine offender of adultery it's
so awesome over 99 of birth control and
it's my taxpayer dollars you have
invited me up in your business and I
will use whatever descript I would like
to
thank you
you know what he's had abortions she's
had more than one obviously there's no
way we don't know but that would be
consistent uh with the Republicans and
also just like a lot of conservative
women have had abortions and still want
to have still want to maintain that like
bodily autonomy he said reportedly to
her I'm just not ready he said we need
to have an abortion baby I'm just not
ready oh damn okay well let's see what
Trump has to say about Herschel you know
maybe he is something I I love you I am
not a gay man and I love you Herschel
Herschel you're fired damn I love you
[Laughter]
like how can I be homophobic my [ __ ] is
gay I love you but I don't swing that
way I love that he's so insecure I love
you I'm not gay I promise I am not a gay
man
here is the the video you were talking
about I really want to see yeah Rebel
when I was running a nasty dishonest
campaign perfect for Washington why did
they put that on screen my full story
look at all the quotes on the little
videos
that's so [ __ ] wild to put that all
the Opera
video
the same here are the things that some
of the folks been saying they're lies
uh Reverend Warnock is running a nasty
dishonest campaign Master dishonest
campaign perfect for Washington
the Reverend doesn't even tell my full
story my true story as everyone knows
you're talking about the newspaper
clipping yeah yeah
look he showed me I think I passed out
and then his face is right next to it
wait and then pull back he held a razor
to her throat threatened to kill her
whoa you'll be like yo I need to read
that article about you bro yeah you took
me I think I passed out like that's
crazy that he posted that he should just
get some like uh he what he needs is uh
some like uh stock photo of a man with a
knife to someone's throat or something
yeah well by the way no I paraphrased
obviously but like it wasn't that far
from what he literally said he's like it
doesn't tell my full story there's a lot
worse yeah they said yeah
my true story as everyone knows I had a
real battle with mental health
even wrote a book about it and by the
grace I even wrote a book about the one
time I tried to kill this woman I didn't
though
to God I'm overcoming one of us a
preacher who doesn't tell the truth he
doesn't even believe in Redemption I'm
Herschel Walker I'm ready well he's
you're basically admitting you did that
exactly you're redeemed about God it's
like bro just say you did all that [ __ ]
yeah well hey don't you but I once try
to kill a woman
something of his mental uh disorders and
that he's like your honor I I have ADHD
Attention Deficit Hyperactive Disorder
it's a real it's a real struggle every
day to not put a knife to my to my
domestic partner's uh throat your honor
I got isn't that is that Christian
Walker what does Christian Walker's mom
that he did all that oh my God yeah holy
yeah yeah yeah no wonder he's so
electromatized yeah exactly [ __ ] up
by the way breaking news breaking
[ __ ] news yeah Biden Joe Biden
[ __ ] dark Brandon
to Pardon all prior Federal offenses of
simple marijuana possession and thank
[ __ ] plays it
this should have happened a long time
ago
we're the fact that people are in prison
for this [ __ ] even now as people are
using legal marijuana is just one of the
biggest travesties of justice and dark
Brandon here
should we spark up in Celebration
it's [ __ ] nice out so were these
people that um
is this a felony were these people who
are unable to or is this a mystery it's
got to be a felony well it's a simple
possession so probably a misdemeanor but
if they're in jail also this is only
Federal people which the article maybe
says I'm not sure I imagine the stats on
the amount of people for simple
possession on federal charges is
probably fairly low what I'm getting at
is the Republican talking point which is
Joe Biden is doing this to get votes
he's getting them all out of prison and
now they voting for him and God damn it
they should because he's a did he did
look at this [ __ ] hell yeah Biden
come on man smoking big joints in Amish
how about he just [ __ ] legalizes in
Alton groomer well that's next but Joe
Biden will pardon all prior Federal
offenses of simple marijuana possession
the pardons will also apply to anyone in
the District of Columbia convicted of
simple possession of marijuana pot
stocks
pot stocks till array Brands and canopy
growth each took a big dub this week
thanks to Joe Budden that's the real
important part love it that's a
beautiful thing you know I love it let's
get some dink doing some doinks going
smoking big doings and Amish do you
think he's
I feel like he's keeping that as the uh
as the trump card pun intended
legalizing you think like right before
the 2024.
I mean it sucks that he's using it as a
political Ploy but if he does it I'll be
so I'll be happy I mean he's doing that
same thing here this is probably because
midterms are coming up you know
I'm telling you dark Brandon has kind of
come out pretty strong here at the end
of his first or that Midway of his first
turn man yeah he want he wants your
children to be potheads he wants your
children to be financially irresponsible
and get big loans to go to college and
then have them repaid unconditionally
you know what I'm talking about dark
Brandon rise the [ __ ] up baby
dark Brandon
yeah this is great news it's just like
wild that
he is
like one of the main reasons uh why
there are such harsh penalties on on
drug offenders
which is wild you know what everybody
can change
he was a massive like I mean he was he
was one of the architects of the you
know he was an advocate an architect of
the crime Bill uh he also uh
collaborated with uh white supremacist
uh
uh white supremacist Strom Thurmond and
others yeah well you once said America
deserved 911. yeah and I stand by that
whereas you know I'm glad that I'm glad
that this is happening I'm just saying
that it is interesting considering that
like he is one of the main people that
it is it is that is responsible for so
many jailed people unjustifiably
especially for drug possession and drug
laws in general and by the way it's so
weird because at the time it was like
everybody was just [ __ ] hated drug
users and marijuana and
it's uh
it's crazy but I'm super glad that he's
you know come around and uh
he's doing it man yeah by the way it
says later in the article it's 6 500
people okay but he set the precedent we
like that
[Music]
one I thought right
more than 100 individuals oh that's out
no it's just and thousands more will be
parted under you uh
so what the [ __ ] is simple marijuana
what kind of charge is that some people
marijuana position I think under like
what is it two ounces four ounces I
think for but for federal it's pretty
low actually I think it's maybe under
it's an ounce or less just one
you can go to jail for that charges yeah
dude it's [ __ ] illegal yes oh my god
let's see more of it we want to see more
of it for sure the position of marijuana
punishable up to one year in jail and a
minimum five of a thousand dollars a
year in jail for first conviction wow
and it is uh the possession is any
amount if you have any amount it's
possession any amount any amount of
marijuana go to jail for a year so that
that threshold is probably set by like
whatever the trafficking law is that
anything above an ounce or whatever
less than 50 kilograms is a felony there
you go
um motivation is less than 50 plants is
a felony what about outnowledge
big old doinks
I'm [ __ ] shocked that they send
people to jail for that that is so
[ __ ] conviction is a mandatory
minimum of 15 days in jail though so
it's like it already has been uh lowered
that's okay like it's not as aggressive
but you do have a mandatory minimum for
that they had to put that in there
that's so funny
and to find up to 2005 500 subsequent
convictions convictions carry a 90-day
mandatory minimum sentence and a maximum
up to three years in prison and a fine
of 5 000 it should have been zero across
the board obviously it's completely
unjustifiable to put someone in the in
the system for something as simple as
like simple possession something is
ridiculous the less the less people in
jail the better man let's get them out
let's close up those [ __ ] slave
factories and yeah get some uh let's
live in a society that
basically doesn't work on slave labor
and locking people up for dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] and ruining lives for no reason
and basically turning people into
criminals in jail because it's so [ __ ]
up there okay Angela Davis
this guy's over here talking our prison
is obsolete I'm out I'm crazy I have
long said Hassan the prisons are
obsolete I think that the um the prison
system in America is probably
one of it's I think it's one of the most
important things that that we need to
solve like in turn I I just it's like
you're absolutely correct one of the
biggest [ __ ] miscarriages of human
dignity and Justice that's happening by
far
I don't want to say in the world but it
is embarrassing it's it's horrific it's
horrific yeah you're you're absolutely
correct uh prisoners have no rights uh
they are mistreated uh regularly uh
convicts are are mistreated it is
absolutely unacceptable it's still in
the Constitution uh 13th amendment
allows you to enslave humans still if
they're prisoners yeah which is [ __ ]
ridiculous I just yeah uh there's a
reason why America has 25 of the entire
incarcerated population of the planet
despite making up four percent of the
entire uh population of the planet one
Area 25 one percent of all Americans are
in jail
that's crazy that's so [ __ ] insane
dude yeah stop of course that disparity
is much larger when you when you look at
uh the black community and you look at
Brock communities like Latino
communities uh obviously that disparity
is is uh not only alarming but
impossible to overlook if you have any
shred of dignity and decency you will
realize that the criminal justice system
and the codes are written in a way
specifically to keep the black
population
uh less Advanced less advantaged and uh
and and undermined
and constantly swinging within the
system there's like a sizable percentage
of like uh young black men that go to
jail or or go to jail once in their life
at least it's like
25 fatherlessness right like it's a
racist uh thing to claim that like black
people uh there's a couple different
studies that disprove that one is that
uh you know they might have
um you know black parents might not uh
uh have the same rate of like uh being
in a marriage
uh while they have children but that
doesn't change the reality of like uh
black fathers are still very much
involved in the lives of their children
but uh one of the other main factors
here to consider is that uh I think it's
one in five black children in this
country have one parent that's
incarcerated that number goes up to one
in 42 for white uh children
that is so [ __ ] insane yeah what do
you say to a conservative would
obviously well black people are just
more violent haven't you read the bell
curve
that's just you're trying to justify
uh what is otherwise the truth which is
uh that there are external factors such
as systemic racism you're trying to
justify racist Behavior with uh faulty
science it's not real science people
have done it for a very long time
they've done it uh in the early 19th
century uh it was very popular very
fashionable to do race realism
phrenology uh skull science for those of
you who don't know it's not real it's
not a real science
um to justify uh enslaving black people
or claiming that black people were
violent uh when in fact it was you know
conditions that we set whether it is
chattel slavery 400 years of that or uh
you know Colonial exploitation
imperialism uh robbing Africa of its
natural wealth and never allowing it to
thrive
uh and and a multitude of different
factors all the way to uh you know
modern day Criminal Justice System uh
disparities in sentencing
uh black and white people consume uh
drugs at the same rate marijuana is a
famous example of this where white
people actually have a tendency to
consume more marijuana but black people
get for all other for all other
conditions uh when you when you factor
in every other condition and you
eliminate like wealth and all this other
stuff when you look at uh a black person
and a white person of similar background
a black person is uh gets like five
times longer sentences
who was a white person for the same
crimes is ridiculous and and
a lot of it I think has to do with like
CL just class based because it's been
historically so hard for black families
to accumulate wealth in this country
because of mortgage laws there was laws
not that long ago that says you can't
give a mortgage to a black you're
describing redlining yes
um there was even a town that was
flourishing that they that white
supremacists literally bombed everybody
talking about Tulsa Oklahoma yeah and so
you know and obviously of course it all
started when they freed the slaves
originally Abraham Lincoln wanted to
give them some land and some money and
[ __ ] and they said [ __ ] that reparations
were given in America did you know this
they were what reparations were actually
given in the United States of America in
the aftermath in the abolition of
slavery yeah they were only given to the
slave owners for every slave that they
had freed awesome and the 40 acres in a
mule that was promised to uh you know
every every newly freed black person was
never given to them well I'll tell you
what similar thing happened in England
as well England's still the kingdom
still pays uh uh I think
uh the kingdom still is paying dues back
to slavers from uh their time in Shadow
slavery
um so that's that's wonderful to think
about like if you're a black person and
you see all this you see a society that
is like designed uh to to enslave you
and designed to oppress you I mean it's
gonna you're not gonna you're not gonna
be too fond of that it's understandable
so it seems like you know class is the
biggest indicator of crime
yes that is that is true however
like racial subjugation
is is enacted on the basis of of class
violence as it always is racial
subjugation is a compounding Factor on
top of class
um racial violence is a compounding
Factor on top of class
uh especially in this day and age but
um it's still classes violence but it's
done on the boundaries of race quite
frequently uh because white supremacy is
a self-defeating Institution for so many
other white people white supremacy kills
white people because you end up voting
for Provisions that end up hurting you
out of your anger for uh for you know
black people existing in society
alongside you
um uh I think it was a republican
strategic strategists that worked uh
with Ronald Reagan that openly stated
that you know back in the 60s you could
say the n-word was a hard R but you know
uh once the Civil Rights Act uh once
Voting Rights Act on the Civil Rights
Movement kicked in you could no longer
say the n-word uh and and therefore you
had to find different ways you said
Force busing uh or you know uh who said
that uh lee Atwater I believe is his
name I don't want to get it wrong P that
man knows how to play the game
um you can't say that anymore so you
start talking about welfare Queens
and at a certain point everybody
understands what you're saying but it's
so abstract but you're still saying the
n-word or you're doing in an abstract
way so that violence uh has has you know
been enacted on the
uh on on a classes basis however
a lot of white people don't recognize
that
um yeah my favorite thing I hear people
say is racism doesn't exist in this
country what are you talking about
anyway
Elon Musk is being forced to buy uh
Twitter oh here's a stat for the chatter
who said that leotard water did work
with Nixon but he also worked with
Reagan as well out of
one out of every three black boys born
today can expect to be sentenced to
prison
whoa one out of three at some point in
their life I was assuming that was this
because there's lots of ways you can
frame the statistics and like what
percentage of current prisoners are
African-American versus you know
um
how many have been to prison but I feel
like that's the most shocking that is
absolutely shocking it goes on to say
one out of six Latino boys which is
super high and one out of 17 white boys
which is also super high too many
[ __ ] people are going to jail right
yeah no I mean obviously way worse
that's how it [ __ ] works that's
that's how it is you you are keeping a
permanent underclass
you were keeping a permit underclass by
putting them in the system and crippling
their their future opportunities in a
country that is ruthlessly violent
towards con uh convicts it even ties
back the [ __ ] cancel culture our
Draconian understanding of crime and
punishment is so pervasive that it plays
a role in the way that we conduct
ourselves even in social media and on
the internet that's part of the reason
why everyone's so [ __ ] vindictive and
refused to lead by empathy and and want
to want to punish people for things that
they consider to be social and moral
failures even if they're even if it
happened a very long a super long time
ago uh and that person has changed it's
it's just a microcosm of that exact uh
identical
way of operating uh reinforcing itself
in our in our day-to-day experiences
with one another
okay just to hit these because it's in
the title Elon Musk buying Twitter for
original price what that's crazy he's
being forced to buy
Twitter that's crazy we'll see what
happens with that eh uh it's literally
the thumbnail of the episode right now
so and then we could talk more about it
tomorrow and then you know what else is
crazy there's a dating app for right
wing people this is actually a really
good segment we put together so
maybe the right wing dating app because
it's a little bit Evergreen and also
we're working to get because it's invite
only right now
um we're working on that we're trying to
get in the system so maybe by next week
we will be in the system so maybe we'll
take right wing dating app off yeah yeah
that's why I'm forced to buy Twitter and
Herschel Walker is a
what do you think so I'm what do we say
about Herschel Walker
um he wants to try to kill a woman he's
a skank he's a skank ass [ __ ] Herschel
Walker is a bit of a manslut that's true
he's a bit of a hoe if she's a skank he
is too Mike no he is way more way more
baby right in her mate
um
yeah what do I have to say by Herschel
Walker no for the title we're doing a
title are you on Force well type Elon
Musk right Elon Musk forced to buy
Twitter Herschel Walker
Herschel Walker campaign imposed like
his baby
oh
too dark
holy [ __ ]
uh Herschel Walker walked his way over
to the abortion clinic and said I'll
take one please I love you I am not a
gay man
uh we'll think of something so so Hassan
thank you for for uh for your time thank
you for being here I know you're a busy
man yeah I'm about to head down to San
Diego over twitchcon okay cool fun
you're gonna be there like all weekend
or what yeah
very cool man
yeah don't try any [ __ ] because you have
tons of bodyguards right yeah I do I
have a [ __ ] I have so much [ __ ]
security don't try any [ __ ] you guys
understand that yeah snipers on the roof
yo if you guys see Hassan at twitchcon
run D for him
let's just get a human shield going
around about around our boy okay yeah no
harm will come to you Hassan oh thank
you can you guarantee that I don't think
so no
it'll be all right suggestion in the
chat Herschel Walker aborts his campaign
love that you think aborts though in the
title is Gonna Get Us
a little risky maybe it will it will
that's what love said he knows okay fair
enough fair enough
all right we'll think of something you
guys got any other ideas Herschel walk
her to the clinic
to the clinic yeah yeah that's good
Herschel Walker walk or just Herschel
walked her to the clinic it's a little
uh it's a little funny but you know
Herschel Walker walked her to the clinic
just to get his name in there for the
SEO you know virtual Walker walked her
to the clinic yeah I mean that's pretty
good we like that it's funny
we like to make abortions funny
oh this one's good from Zachary Herschel
Walker early campaign termination
[Laughter]
that's very funny that's a good one
that's a good one too first first
trimester campaign termination
oh yeah we like that
Rachel Walker
Herschel Walker murders a baby
we cannot no you don't like that
parentheses by by his logic by his own
Logic No No all right all right guys
thank you so much we'll be here on
Friday it's after dark Hassan uh enjoyed
twitchcon
have fun over there and we'll see you
next week for another episode of
leftovers
signing out from our 20 billion dollar
bunker hell yeah brother
hell yeah so uh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]